achso und ihr müsst euch mich natürlich
als mädchen vorstellen weil denkt
einfach ich halt schon toll wie immer
[Musik]
willkommen beim neuen video und zu hab
ich genau heute vor einer woche das
video gemacht was jungs so wirklich
wirklich vorm schlafengehen machen und
das ziemlich gut bei euch angekommen ich
habe ja gefragt wo soll ich nicht
vielleicht mal sowas mädchen wirklich
vorm einschlafen machen machen machen
machen machen und ihr habt mir ganz
viele kommentare geschrieben was ihr
mädchen wirklich vom schlafen macht das
gucken wir uns heute mal an und let's go
sso und ja wenn es euch gefällt könnt
ihr gern nach oben geben schreibt auch
weitere dinge ob jetzt ein junger seite
von mädchen darin die kommentare was
macht die jungs oder mädchen so heimlich
alles vom schlafen gehen und jetzt
fangen wir waren erste kommentar hatte
glaube ich über 100 likes mädchen vor
dem schlafen schnell noch mal den status
und so vor dem schwaben stockreiter das
ist voll schwer auszusprechen aber ja
das glaube ich euch vor allem was ich
wirklich so geil finde ich meinen sohn
sein status den kann man richtig so
auseinandernehmen interpretieren wie
gegen so einen scheiß langweiliges
gedicht im deutschunterricht und ich
kann mir auch ein bisschen vorstellen
wieder so ungefähr aussehen könnte
endlich schlafen obwohl ein ich kann ihn
doch mal schnell den status von alex
checken ich war doch so heftig auf den
appell nicht jeder schatz besteht aus
silber und gold moment mal das kann doch
eigentlich nur ein zeichen sein
silber fängt mit ass andres chantal also
bald mit es weil ich bestehe nicht aus
silber oder gold das kann doch jetzt
eigentlich nur heißen dass der alex mich
meint oder vielleicht ist das ja auch
ein hinweis auf den geheimen ort wo er
mich treffen will man kompliziert diese
jungs absolut ihr müsst euch mich
natürlich als mädchen vorstellen weil
denkt einfach ich heiß schon teil
wie immer kommen wir zu dem top
kommentar der top comments wenn mädchen
verliebt sind stellen sie sich vor dem
schlafzimmer vor was wohl am nächsten
morgen passieren wird oder was ihr mit
ihm tun werden ja ja ja das hört sich
jetzt schon ziemlich erotisch an kann
ich mir auch gut vorstellen was da so
abgeht bei euch
ich freue mich schon wenn ich morgen die
schule komme ich werde erwartet dort auf
mich kommt auf mich zu
zieht sich moment ich bin in der schule
kommt auf mich zu
am abend nicht und sagt ich bin die
ganze scheiße alter zwar nur ein kleiner
witz am rande
alex kam damals nicht okay und kommen
wir zu einem nächsten kommentar dann
habe ich wirklich so oft lesen und zwar
wie überlegen 1000 stunden was wir
anziehen könnten
so weist es so ich denke mir so als
junge ist das ja kein ding
manchmal denke ich auch so zwei drei
minuten nach aber ich habe so viele
sachen irgendwas finde ich immer problem
bei den mädchen können dann seien die
haben so viele von diesen so vielen
sachen dass sie so viele sachen haben
und halt gar nicht wissen welche dieser
ganz vielen sachen sie jetzt tragen
sollten macht sinne aber da kann ich
euch so ein beispiel mit auf den weg
geben was mich wirklich andauernd
betrifft ich habe dass das passiert mir
wirklich sauer auf und zwar hat es
vielleicht keine studie belegt aber das
ist einfach so dass hat alex studie
herausgefunden also fast auf jeder
einzelne von uns ist so immer
automatisch weniger mit seinem
äußerlichen zufrieden als andere sind
deswegen wenn man so denkt also ich
denke manchmal so zum beispiel wo alex
heute sie aber echt scheiße aus und dann
gehe ich abends wenn ich disco so von
wegen so was geht hier ab mit aber immer
noch heute siehst du scheiße aus ihr
jetzt sogar hier saison bringt also ich
komme dann in die disco dortmund
dann kommen die ganzen [ __ ] an und
ich denke mir neue studie herausgefunden
nein spaß leute so ist es vielleicht
auch nicht aber das ist finde ich
wirklich so man ist selber immer viel
weniger mit seinen äußerungen zufrieden
wenn man denkt die roten fußballschuh
aus heute andere sehen das halt komplett
anders deswegen ihr könnt ihr eure
meinung dazu und in die kommentare
schreiben würde mich echt interessieren
wie seht ihr das so leitet down and user
kommentare jetzt alles klar kommen wir
zum letzten kommentar fast jeder bei
mädchen doppelpunkt die haare machen
obwohl man weiß dass sie am nächsten
morgen wieder scheiße aussehen
[Musik]
so kann ich schlafen gehen
ja heute das war's mit diesem video wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann wird sich sehr
freuen wenn ihr daumen nach oben da las
dann sehe ich auch das gefallen hat
ansonsten ist der chat instagram wales
eingependelt
ich bin jetzt gerade im skiurlaub
nächste woche kommt allerdings ganz
normal ein paar videos 23 videos vier
videos also keine ahnung
werdet ihr sehen instagram habe ich
schon gesagt dass wir uns auch weiter
mit einem check das aber nicht vergessen
hatte und bis dienstag 2